[Música]
esta mujer influencer se hace Llamar
Annie Se presenta como una joven y
propone llevarlos a recorrer un campo de
algodón cerca de su casa en la región
Autónoma de yin yang al este de China
en YouTube se puede encontrar cientos de
videos como este realizados por mujeres
jóvenes que se presentan como ulgures y
destacan su cultura y tradiciones pero
hay algo en este tipo de vídeos que
llamará atención los ubures musulmanes
en su mayoría son violentamente
discriminados en China y cuando se
pertenece a esta etnia publicar un vídeo
en YouTube no es un asunto trivial así
le explica esta mujer presidenta del
instituto
la sanción por utilizar estos sitios
extranjeros puede tener consecuencias
muy graves es una de las 75 señales de
radicalización para ser enviado a un
campo de concentración
y luego condenado a fuertes penas de
prisión
para los activistas las jóvenes como
Annie Willy son parte de la propaganda
china que niega la realidad de la
represión contra las minorías
al menos un millón de personas están
internadas en llamados campos de
rehabilitación y Beijing pretende borrar
abiertamente cualquier particularidad
cultural
lo que nos resulta especialmente
interesante Aquí son las influencers que
muestran que la cultura es presentada
tal cual
precisamente
y que la lengua no ha sido atacada y que
los hugures están felices de vivir bajo
El dominio chino
también hay videos similares en YouTube
grabados o por tibetanos
casacos
[Música]
todos estos grupos minoritarios son
blanco de la misma política agresiva de
unificación cultural de Medellín ese
tipo de contenido intrigó a un grupo de
investigadores australianos Así que
estudiaron más de 1.700 contenidos y
esto fue lo que encontraron
ha habido muchísimos casos documentados
de wigures y cazacos detenidos por
utilizar aplicaciones internacionales
ilegales en China como YouTube
Así que el hecho de que estas
influencers parecieran tener un pase
especial para publicar en YouTube sin
ninguna repercusión en la vida real era
muy sospechoso
y resultó que la mayoría de estas
jóvenes son muy cercanas a los círculos
políticos
algunas de ellas Son miembros activos
del partido comunista chino
pronto nos dimos cuenta de que las
cuentas de estas influencers estaban en
realidad gestionadas por empresas
privadas llamada redes multicanal en
China estas empresas están vinculadas al
partido comunista chino porque por ley
están obligadas a adherirse a las
prioridades y al programa del partido
por ejemplo estas son guli mayor y guli
menor dos jóvenes vinculadas a una de
estas empresas tenían perfiles en
Twitter Instagram tiktok y YouTube antes
de que fueran eliminados en el año 2021
eh os he enseñado a culito acaba
uno de los videos promueve el turismo en
Shin yang al final se mencionan dos
instituciones relacionadas con la
censura y la propaganda en China el
contenido de estas influencers se
encuentra a veces incluso directamente
en los medios de propaganda
tradicionales chinos particularmente en
las embajadas chinas en el extranjero
la mayoría de estos videos entran en la
categoría de estilo de vida
hablan de cachorros o de reunirse con la
familia para comer la comida tradicional
pero también ocultan aspectos concretos
de la vida de estos grupos étnicos
por ejemplo no hacen referencia a su fe
y sus videos están desprovistos de
cualquier contenido religioso
así que solo hablan de las cosas más
mundanas Y de lo bien que sus familiares
hablan el chino mandarín En comparación
con su primera lengua que sería el
wiwire o el tibetano
total
estos videos de estilo de vida y
propaganda implícita son los más
eficaces porque parecen muy Auténticos
en estos videos que clasificamos como
propaganda implícita se habla de viajes
o de desarrollo económico
y luego están los videos de propaganda
mucho más explícitos en los que algunas
de estas influencers en particular las
wigures desmienten los informes
extranjeros sobre por ejemplo el trabajo
forzado
afirman que todo está bien y describen
una forma de vida idílica en esa
regiones
en YouTube
para los investigadores de este
instituto australiano estas cuentas no
deben ser necesariamente bloqueadas ya
que a pesar de todo ofrecen según ellos
una visión del modo de vida de ciertas
personas en las regiones en cuestión en
particular le piden a YouTube que ponga
de manifiesto los vínculos entre estas
cuentas y el partido comunista chino y
que evite la monetización de estos
contenidos
[Música]
así llegamos al final de los
observadores por esta semana quieren
alertarnos sobre algo enviarnos imágenes
que tomaron O vieron en particular Pues
todos nuestros contactos aparecen en
pantalla y nuestro sitio web France
24.com hace una próxima oportunidad